and and you can see and i see this so
interesting too that
the legacy media uh types are
they're done they're so done it's and
it's happened so fast
i notice among young people that the
legacy media
the big magazines the newspapers the tv
stations the radio stations for that
matter
all of whom had a monopoly on this kind
of information flow
are so dead to people under 30 that it's
as if
their death isn't even noticed and
that's fascinating and yesterday
i i interviewed richard trombley and
richard tremblay
is a is in his 80s and he's a scientist
who studied
male aggression a research scientist who
studied male and female aggression for
40 years and he's won the criminologists
equivalent of the nobel prize and the
order of canada which is canada's
knighthood for all intents and purposes
hundreds of publications a very
distinguished scientist and
we had a two-hour conversation and i
thought afterwards i thought you know
i've only been able to have
conversations like that
in graduate seminars in the highest
quality graduate seminars
in the most elite universities now and
then
even though i was placed to have those
conversations two hours on a single
topic
covered in as much depth as possible um
by by someone who's a world authority
and now i can have that conversation
with people
and 150 000 to a million people can have
access to it instantly
it's like i think
god only knows what that is going to be
the consequence of that
so it's so fun to to play around with
this and to experiment with it and
and it's such a privilege to be able to
do it and there's so much possibility in
it so
and i've also been trying to figure out
what i'm doing with the podcasts
themselves because that's really what
i've been
doing a lot of for the last four months
and i listened to this
i was interviewed by a wall street
journalist last week
and i asked him what he liked about
podcast because he listened to them a
lot and he said i really like to see
where they're going
and i thought yeah that's exactly it
because in a
legacy media interview everything is
scripted and you're never talking to a
person you're talking to the
corporation essentially and i'm not
being cynical about that
it had to be that way because bandwidth
was so expensive
but now you can sit down with someone
and you can risk exploration of course
that's what joe rogan has been doing so
well for so many years you can risk
exploration
you can have two people having a genuine
discussion about a complex issue and so
they're they're engaging in dialectical
thinking and if they're good at it
they're modeling it
so they can model high quality
dialectical thinking
and pull people along on an exploratory
journey
and make it permanent and that's
completely revolutionary
that's never been possible before and
and
and the possibilities are um
limitless and then sorry i'm going to
rant about this a bit because i i am so
continually staggered by this the next
thing is you can take those
conversations
and you can chop them up into 30 second
pieces of minute long pieces five minute
long pieces 20 minute long pieces
and each of those can find a specialized
home that can attract millions of views
and so it's as if you could write a book
and sell it by the sentence
it's it's really something so well so
that's
you know all response to red skull i
suppose
the interesting thing that i think i
enjoy about podcasts and a lot of
audiences do as well is that unscripted
nature
but it's not just the fact that the
topics are unscripted it's the
the cadence and the the timbre of the
the tone of the way that the
conversation flows as well
if you struggle to work something out
if you're battling at the forefront of
your own cognitive capacity to try and
get something from brain to mouth we get
to hear
i'm brought along and where it's almost
like a football match or a sports game
we're willing the person to get to the
goal absolutely
yep it is exactly like that it's a it it
it it's
it's your the analogy is directly
appropriate
that's why people like football and
soccer games look those
they the players are trying to put
something into the goal
well that's what you're doing when
you're having a genuine dialogue
you know it isn't necessarily clear what
the goal is it's more implicit because
you're
starting to make that more and more
clear too but
but and and there is something engaging
about
participating in that apparently as a
listener as well as a participant and i
can tell perfectly well
when a podcast discussion is going well
and it's a dance
right i mean there's there has to be
this continual reciprocity and
that requires you to attend very
carefully to your guest
and to listen i have some trouble with
not interrupting because
for a variety of reasons but some of
that's the technological lag produced by
the
by zoom and skype it makes you a little
less uh
what the dance is a little more awkward
because the timing is off
but it's it's really fun when it works
and
it's working much of the time when i'm
talking to my guests
it's really exciting
i have all sorts of people lined up i'm
so excited about it
yeah yeah long may continue i really do
think that it's
it's such an answer to so much bad media
and bad thinking
and it gives a platform to people who
can't hide behind
media training anything and script can't
hide behind anything no there is no
place to i don't think
i think no there's no place to hide i
think that if in two hours you reveal
your hand
and everyone can see it you reveal the
weaknesses and strengths of your
argument you reveal the weaknesses and
strengths of your
character you know but but in some sense
you can
even if your character is flawed like
all of our characters are
you know if you're engaged in something
genuine and in a genuine move forward
you're forgiven for that right it is if
if you're if you're actively rectifying
your evident flaws during the discussion
people will forgive you for your flaws
but
youtube and podcast long form seems
absolutely unforgiving of any
falsity as far as i can tell i mean
sometimes we do some editing
there's two conditions under which we'll
edit one is just to edit out some
technical glitch
we also allow our guests the option of
not having something they said broadcast
if they believe they've made a factual
error or addressed an argument in a
misleading way
and that's a little bit more of a moral
quagmire but our thought is that
if we allow people that veto power to
begin with they're much more likely to
be
loose and to take risks in the
exploration
and we've had to cut virtually nothing
except
i think two factual errors of a few
seconds but
it's so interesting because in the
comments section if we ever edit
anything
there's skepticism right away and so
and so that's another indication of how
unforgiving
the medium is with regards to falsity
i'm trying to get politicians on my
podcast i
senator mike lee who's probably the most
conservative senator
in the united states i'm releasing a
podcast with him this weekend and i
think he acquitted himself well
um and i'm hoping that i'm i'm i've been
in contact with a large number of
democrats
and i'm hoping that they'll take the big
leap because
they can talk directly to their
constituents
they can talk directly to the people who
they're responsible to with no
intermediation of
bureaucracy if they dare that's
that's the thing because when it's
unedited when it's a flowing
conversation for a long amount of time
the precipice on either side you are
walking a tightrope as you said
there is no opportunity to go away and
check what you actually want to say and
rewrite it in a script it is
riding the crest of now constantly
surfing the wave of the crest of now um
i think it's going to find out who
it's a genuineness
test like a canary in the coal mine for
how genuine someone is
because there's no way that you can hold
up a persona for two hours straight
yeah well or or or maybe somewhat more
forgiving than that it might be a canary
test for how genuine they're
they're attempting to move towards
because like i said i think you can make
mistakes but
but but if if you're
bargaining in good faith the audience
will forgive you for your for your
mistakes
so but but you're punished brutally if
you're false
so and i don't know about you but i'm
really attentive to the comments i watch
how people are responding and
you know if 10 people point out
something i'm still working on this
proclivity to interrupt but
if 10 people point out something i try
to address it my team tries to address
it because
well why not you know i mean you're
probably doing something wrong
at some point and enough people will
tell you it's tricky
but it's at least worth considering
thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy peace
you